mais
on
le premier raid radio sunderland fut
livré la rfa en 1938
commença alors l'une des plus longues
carrières qu'un avion de guerre n'est
jamais fait
il fut l'un des seuls avions à opérer
pendant toute la seconde guerre mondiale
est le seul avion de la rfa accomplir
des missions sur le front pendant toute
la durée de la guerre de corée
lorsqu'il prit sa retraite en 1959 ils
avaient accompli un total de 21 années
de service ci avait acquis la réputation
d'être un avion solide et sûr de
nombreuses compagnies aériennes
britanniques et autres utilisent l
essonne der linde et leurs semblables au
cours de la période d'après guerre
lorsque la r f mis fin à ses activités
en extrême orient en mai 59
la carrière de l'hydravion sunderland
pris fin de nos jours le seul survivant
et cet ancien hydravion de la r f
le ml 814
construit suivant le modèle du mark iii
en même temps que 24 autres appareils il
quitta les usines short à belfast et fut
livrée à la 57e unités d'entretien en
mai 1944 au cours des deux dernières
années de la guerre il servit dans la
201e escadrille de la royal air force et
dans la 422e escadrille de l'armée de
l'air canadienne
en 1945 il fut transformé en un marque 5
est envoyé à la 272e unités d'entretien
avant d'être transféré dans l'armée de
l'air néo-zélandaise sous le nom de nzt
41,08 lorsque sa carrière pris fin il
fut acheté par une entreprise
australienne
la nd flying boat service de brisbane
sous le nom de island rml 814 ou vh brf
dans les registres civils
il fut utilisé par la compagnie n 7
jusqu'en 1974 vendu aux antilles herbes
hautes
il fut rebaptisé excalibur oui tu es
servi encore six années outre mer en mai
1981 il fut racheté par edouard oulton
il fut ramené des bermudes en angleterre
en l'honneur du principal concepteur du
sunderland il fut rebaptisé soeur arthur
gauche est inscrit dans le registre
civil sous le matricule gba j s
il resta jusqu'à la fin des années 80
sur ses amarres à chattam avant de
rejoindre au début des années 90 sont
présents domicile aux états unis
non
en 1908 la société charles brothers
limited fut créée par trois des plus
grands pionniers dans l'histoire de
l'aviation les frères horace albert et
yuke chante il avait déjà créé un
commerce florissant en fabriquant des
montgolfières pour de riches d'aviateur
amateurs l'entreprise devra ensuite le
premier constructeur d'avions de
commerce au monde
en deux ans les frères chante avaient
bâti leur première entreprise de
construction aéronautique et avait
commencé à mettre au point leur premier
avion
le biplan short numéro un en 1913 le
potentiel de leur avion fut testée afin
que soient estime et son utilité dans la
marine pendant ce temps wiston churchill
avait déjà employé le terme hydravion
lorsque les shorts reçurent les premiers
contrats de la marine
la production hydravion n'est assurée
que par les douze employés de la
nouvelle usine de rochester implanté
près de la rivière medway dans le kent
au cours de la première guerre mondiale
lusine construisit des hydravions de
reconnaissance et de patrouilles anti
sous marins pour la marine britannique
les hydravions de petite taille comme le
184 le 320 fut rapidement suivi par le
premier grand titre avions deux frères
schoch ben le félix stone un bimoteur
cette gamme de bimoteurs en bois survécu
à la guerre et le f5 félix tao restent
en service pendant une grande partie des
années 20 au cours des dix années qui
suivirent l'entreprise pas ça de la
construction traditionnelle en bois à
les appareils plus innovateurs équipés
de fuselage métallique l'un des premiers
résultats de ce changement fut
l'hydravion short singapour marc hein
en 1927 1 singapour 1 fut prêté au
ministère de la navigation aérienne afin
d'entreprendre relevés aériens de
l'afrique de quelques quarante et un
mille quatre cents kilomètres pour le
compte de l'impérial airways
cet appareil propulsé par des moteurs
rolls royce de 800 chevaux et des
hélices fut pilotée par sera lan cobham
après que ceux relevés aériens fut
terminée en 28 les shorts modifièrent le
modèle du mark 1 afin de pouvoir équiper
de trois moteurs au lieu de deux ce
nouvel appareil fut baptisé le calcutta
l'impérial airways en commande à 1 et
des 28 il devint l'un des premiers
hydravion être utilisé comme avion de
commerçants de grande bretagne
une version militaire fut rapidement
créée et baptisée rangoun lorsqu'il
entre en service en 31 il va compléter
la flotte de la rff une flotte toujours
croissante d'hydravion de grande taille
servant des opérations de reconnaissance
générale vers le milieu des années
trente l'impérial airways reçu l'accord
du gouvernement pour développer une
série de routes aériennes rapide
efficace dans tout l'empiré britannique
et c'est ainsi que des passagers furent
transportés en afrique en inde en
australie en extrême orient
mais ce nouveau service permet également
d'améliorer largement les délais de
livraison du transport postal de lempire
l'impérial airways décida d'utiliser des
hydravions sur chacune des principales
routes aériennes
après avoir livré des calcutta la
compagnie aérienne il fut également
demandé aux shorts de mettre au point un
nouvel appareil capable de transporter
des passagers et du courrier sur de très
grandes distances
au lieu de se baser sur le modèle
traditionnel des biplans le principal
concepteur arthur gouges opta pour un
monoplan dont les ailes serait placé
assez haut sur l'appareil
les plans furent établis pour un
hydravion à quatre moteurs capables de
transporter un chargement de cinq tonnes
de passagers de cargaison
appelez les aces 23 est considéré par
impérial airways comme des appareils de
classe c les deux premiers hydravion
canopus et caledonia entreprirent leur
vol inaugural au cours de l'été 1936 peu
après que les premières commandes eurent
été honorés près de trente hydravion se
retrouvèrent au service de
l'impérialisme et près d'une quinzaine
étaient utilisés par la compagnie
d'aviation australienne cuenca ce
parallèlement à la mise au point du m23
un programme était également créé pour
trouver un remplaçant ou singapour 3 en
1933 le ministère de la navigation
aérienne avait fourni un cahier des
charges
r2 33 commandant monoplan à quatre
moteurs un appareil de reconnaissance
maritime qui pourrait en fin de compte
remplacer le biplan 5 à pau
les frères choc proposèrent le s 25 un
modèle très semblable en taille en
apparence os 23 gauche soumis le modèle
en 34 la coque de l'appareil était plus
vaste des sons et plus long que ceux du
s 23
il était également équipé de deux
mitrailleuses l'une monter dans la queue
et l'autre à l'avant de l'appareil
lorsque le prototype fut prêt il était
de plus équipé d'une tourelle à l'avant
renfermant une mitrailleuse 303 de deux
mitrailleuses placés sur les côtés du
fuselage et d'une tourelle à l'arrière
de l'appareil
abritant quatre autres mitrailleuses 303
c'était le premier avion britannique à
être équipée de touraine muni d'un
armement de défense en mars 1936 le
ministère de la navigation aérienne
passe à une première commande de 21
appareils et 18 mois plus tard le 16
octobre 1937 le cas à 47,74 entrepris
son vol inaugural après avoir modifié la
disposition des ailes le prototype fille
d'autres vols d'essais au cours du
printemps de l'année suivante
l'appareil porte maintenant le nom de
sunderland était propulsé par quatre
moteurs bristol pégase 22 développement
un peu plus de 1000 chevaux chacun alors
que le prototype n'était encore qu'à ses
vols d'essais
les frères chante avait déjà commencé à
construire la première série de mark 1
en 1938 les premiers avions étaient
prêts et furent livrés à la rfo mois de
juin la 230e escadrille basée à celle
tard à singapour et la 210e escadrille
de pembroke dock furent les premiers à
recevoir ces nouveaux appareils
les deux escadrilles remplacèrent leur
biplan singapour par les thunder landes
les équipages de ces avions furent tout
d'abord stupéfait il n'avait jamais vu
une coque creuse de cette taille je
faisais tout d'abord partie de la 228e
l'escadrille base et appelant rock doc
je pense qu'à l'époque nous étions tous
très enthousiastes de piloter un avion
moderne car nous avions l'habitude de
piloter d'anciens avions
ce nouvel avion était un monoplan il
était vraiment au sommet de la
technologie aérienne c'était le plus
grand avion opéré dans le monde
tout cela était vraiment très excitant
pour un pilote de 19 ans comme moi il
était très excitant d'être le capitaine
d'un terrifiant parce que vous étiez
responsable de votre équipage et de cet
avion alors que vous vous trouviez en
plein milieu de l'atlantique
la seule personne qui pouvait ramener
l'avion à sa base s'était vous car la
radio n'existait pas il n'y avait que le
silence vous ne disposiez d'aucun
système de pilotage automatique d'aucun
radar vous étiez donc bien le seul à
pouvoir ramener l'avion à sa base et je
trouve que cela était vraiment très
excitant
vous deviez tout calculé par vos propres
moyens vos calculs y est votre altitude
si vous utilisiez le sextant marin au
lieu du sextant aérien vous pouviez vous
retrouver vingt pieds plus bas que prévu
comme nous pouvions malgré tout recevoir
des messages de la base
si nous n'avions pas prévenu l'opérateur
que nous changions d'altitude il le
disait alors nous avons perdu votre
trace où êtes vous de plus votre
navigateur faisait ses estimations à vue
simplement en regardant par le hublot
il estimait ainsi la force du fonds
chaque avion transporter deux pigeons
voyageurs
si vous vous écrasez en mer
le bailleur moyens de signaler votre
opposition était d'envoyer un pigeon
voyageur à la pâte duquel vous aviez
attaché un message ce pigeon retourner à
l'heure à la base et signalez votre
position ça c'était la procédure
officielle mais on prétendait qu'il y
avait un moyen encore plus efficace si
vous étiez perdu vous deviez sortir le
pigeon de son panier vous le placier sur
la table du navigateur acier
ligne qui a dit qu est votre position
par rapport à celle de la base
et si le pigeon faisait un signe de tête
cela signifiait que vous étiez sur la
bonne route
même s'il se trouvait loin de la base la
plus proche de sunderland pouvait
demeurer longtemps autonome vide le
marque un peser environ 12 tonnes et
demie avec une cargaison complète il
pouvait peser plus de 20 tonnes les
mises au point futur lui permettrait
d'augmenter son poids total de près de 7
tonnes les performances du sunderland
constituait donc un progrès de taille
par rapport à ses prédécesseurs avec une
vitesse maximale de quelques 380
kilomètres par heure
il était d'environ 130 km par heure plus
rapide que le singapore mark iii il
pouvait monter jusqu'à plus de 20 mille
pieds et les quatre moteurs pégase lui
permettait de monter de quelques 12
cents pieds par minute presque deux fois
plus rapidement que le singapore les six
réservoirs principaux placé sous les
ailes et les quatre réservoirs
auxiliaires pouvait contenir jusqu'à 11
1250 litres de carburant en permettant
ainsi à cet hydravion de couvrir une
distance sans précédent de près de 5400
km
le sunderland était en règle générale
d'équipé de deux mitrailleuses à l'avant
et de 4 à l'arrière le mark 1 et est
équipé de deux mitrailleuses qui était
adapté sur le fuselage même de telle
sorte qu'elles pouvaient être orientés
dans toutes les directions
plus tard au cours des opérations menées
dans le nord de l'atlantique de
mitrailleuses de 50 furent placés dans
le nez de l'appareil afin de répondre
efficacement au changement de tactique
adoptée par les sous marins allemands
à mon époque les sous-marins plongeait
alors qu'il repérait un avion nous
devions alors utiliser nos grenades
sous-marines contenant chacune quelque
110 kilos d'explosifs
ces grenades explosent et à une
profondeur de nez
et alors vous pouviez modifier cette
profondeur de 3 2 6 ou voir même de 15
mètres lorsque sous marin plongez vous
deviez orienter votre appareil dans la
même direction que le sous-marin est
poussé ensuite sur ce que nous appelions
le mickey mouse le bouton qui
déclenchait les charges et ainsi le
sous-marin explosait plus tard les
sous-marins re sur de nouvelles
instructions
il devait rester en surface c'est
répondre aux attaques des avions c'était
une très mauvaise nouvelle pour les
équipages de sunderland car il ne
disposait pas de l'armement nécessaire
pour se défendre et donc de nombreuses
sunderland furent abattus
on décida alors d'équiper les sunderland
2 mitrailleuses 2.5 à l'avant de
l'appareil
ces armes avaient un plus grand rayon
d'action et atteignez donc plus souvent
leurs cibles et vous pouviez alors
répondre aux tirs ennemis
en tant qu'avion militaire le thunder
line pouvait transporter un peu plus de
900 kilos de bombes d'explosifs ou de
mines devra est muni d'un moteur furent
montés sous les halles et lorsque
l'hydravion entrer en action les armes
avancées sur ce rail et apparaissait à
l'extérieur par les vastes et qu'outil
situés sur les côtés du fuselage de
l'appareil
derrière le compartiment réservé aux
mécaniciens le pont supérieur
transportait toute une gamme de
fumigènes et de fusées éclairantes à
l'arrière et sous ce pont était rangée
d'autres équipements entre autres des
fusées de détresse c'est une caméra de
reconnaissance un canot des réserves de
nourriture en cas d'urgence et même
trois pales d'hélices de rechange à
l'extrémité du pont inférieur un petit
passage fermé par une toile donner accès
à l'empennage stabilisateur yaya touré
l'arrière
à l'avant de la coque sous la cabine de
pilotage se trouvait la place du
bombardier est derrière lui un canoë
l'espace réservé à lancre la tourelle à
vent était monté sur un rail ainsi
lorsque l'avion a merry c'est la
tourelle pouvait être rentré et la
grande d'encre pouvait être rejetée par
cette ouverture
immédiatement sur les cabines de
pilotage se trouvaient les toilettes
l'escalier et connexions le cari un
espace de repos lorsque la guerre éclate
en septembre 39 quelques 40 sunderland
était en service la 228e escadrille
basée à pembroke dock ainsi que la 210e
avait commencé à s'équiper de nouveaux
hydravion dix mois plus tôt et en avril
1939 elle possédait 890 d'
la 204e escadre et commencent à
s'équiper en juin et à la fin du mois
suivant elle dispose également de 8
hydravion supplémentaires en juillet la
10e escadrille de la force aérienne
australienne arrivée au royaume uni pour
venir prendre livraison de ces nouveaux
appareils et y resta jusqu'à la fin de
la guerre elle fut ainsi la première
escadrille australienne à servir en
europe au cours de la seconde guerre
mondiale
lorsque les hostilités s'intensifièrent
les sunderland pour entreprendre le type
d'opération pour lesquels il était
véritablement équiper les longues et
pénibles patrouille maritime
souvent ils ne rencontraient rien
d'autre que des kilomètres et des
kilomètres d'océan
mais le 18 septembre 1939 ils
remportèrent l'un de leurs premiers
succès torpiller à quelque 125 km au
large de sorlingues par un sous marin
allemand
les 34 membres d'équipage du ss
kensington cordes s'étaient regroupés
dans les canots de sauvetage
deux hydravions de la 204e et 228e
escadrille leur porter secours et une
heure après que leurs bateaux étaient
écoulés l'équipage se retrouver en
angleterre
ce fut la première opération de ce type
dans l'histoire de la rfm grazel tous
les thunder line furent équipés d'un
radio goniomètre je faisais partie de la
base de poggio un jour que nous étions
en patrouille
loin de pembroke dock nous avions repéré
trois sous-marins japonais il se
trouvait à la surface de l'eau et ils
avaient orienté leurs armes dans notre
direction
halifax apparu alors et futon dommages
et par les tirs des sous marins un autre
sunderland rejoignit et nous sommes
restés quelques temps hors de portée des
sous marins ensuite l'un des sous-marins
manoeuvra et se retrouve à séparer des
deux autres mon navigateur qui était un
homme très expérimenté me dit alors on y
va
et nous étions tellement bas que nous
avons failli heurter le périscope nous
avons largué une grenade sous-marine à
l'avant du sous marin et nous avons
entendu une formidable explosion chaud
peu après
avons vu qu'une nappe de carburant se
répandait sur l'eau et il semblait que
les centaines de marins pataugeaient
dans ce carburant
c'est vrai que nous mêmes nous sentions
c'est audard et c'était la première fois
que nous voyons de les hommes jusqu
alors nous n'avions que le sous-marin
l'appareil
c'est alors qu'on entendit un japonais
dire ils n'ont leur geek qu'une seule
grenades sous-marines nous en
transportions généralement deux nous
avons largué la seconde
ensuite nous avons vu arriver le 5 j'ai
eu 88 qui avait probablement été appelé
en renfort par les trois sous-marins
mais il arrivait quelques instants trop
tard qu'ils ont alors repéré la nappe de
carburant et l'équipage du sous-marin
heureusement pour nous car cela nous a
permis de remonter et de nous cacher
dans les nuages
nous avons pu ainsi nous éloigner nous
avons vraiment eu de la chance ce jour
là
bien qu'au début de la guerre les
hydravions ne remportait que peu de
succès sur les sous marins allemands 1
sunderland de la 228e escadre y joue un
rôle capital dans la destruction de l'un
des premiers sous-marins le 30 janvier
1948 n 90 25
escortés en convoi au sud-ouest de
sorlingues lorsque son équipage repéra 1
9 55 devant faire face au sunderland et
se trouvant sous la menace de deux
bâtiments de guerre britannique le sloop
flowers et le destroyer oui tu cèdes le
commandant du sous-marin préféra
détruire son bâtiment plutôt que de se
rendre
bien que pour la première fois un
soderling avait contribué à la
destruction d'un sous-marin les
hydravions durent faire face à une
situation de plus en plus difficile
lorsque hitler envahit la norvège en
avril 1940 l'allemagne étant dit son
contrôle à de nouvelles eaux côtières
disposant maintenant de nouvelles bases
d'opération les sous-marins menacèrent
de plus en plus les convois de
ravitaillement vitaux pour les
britanniques n'étant toujours pas
équipée d'un véritable appareil de
détection efficace il était impossible
aux hydravions de localiser efficacement
un sous marin sauf si leur équipage le
repérer à l'oeil nu
même s'il en repérer un les seules armes
anti sous marine dont disposait le
sunderland était des bombes hautement
explosive qui utilisait généralement la
rff celle ci n'était que peu efficace
sur la coque d'un sous marin et la
situation ne s'améliorera que lorsque
les bombes furent remplacées par des
grenades sous-marines bien plus efficace
mais en dépit de quelques problèmes
qu'avait posé des armes anti sous marins
l'armement défensive du sunderland
s'avéra très efficace au cours d'un vol
d' escort au dessus de la mer du nord le
3 avril 1940 1 sunderland de la 204e
escadre y fut attaqué par six john kirby
eu 88 au cours de la bataille aérienne
qui s'ensuivit un appareil allemand fut
abattu un second dû se poser en
catastrophe en norvège et des quatre
autres furent mis en fuite
nous étions attaqué par six j'ai eu 88
qui adoptait une tactique plus efficace
il y en avait de chaque côté dans nos
appareils
si nous essayons de viry d'hbo nous nous
exposions tir de trois autres appareils
ils n'ont pas commencé à nous attaquer
immédiatement pendant le combat
nous avons remarqué que l'un des
appareils échapper de la fumée
nous avons dû le toucher mais tout était
tellement confus que nous n'avions pas
vu que nous l'avions touchés nous nous
cachions dans les nuages puis nourrit
apparition par temps clair il aurait été
très difficile de ne pas se faire
abattre par 6 juin 88 mais il y avait ce
jour-là suffisamment de nuages pour se
cacher et nous avons pu retourner à la
base
un incident semblable eu également lieu
quelques temps plus tard dans le golfe
de gascogne lorsqu un hydravion fut
attaqué par pas moins de 8 j eu 88
cette fois les gravillons abati 3 des
appareils qu'ils avaient attaqué et les
autres furent mis en fuite
ces incidents et de nombreux autres
heures provoquèrent le plus grand
respect des allemands pour le sunderland
il le surnommèrent même le porc-épic
volant
beaucoup
en fait
m
e
non
vu que les affrontements s'intensifient
en mer les shorts essayer d'améliorer le
sunderland
les quelques modifications apportées
permirent de produire différentes
variantes du thunder lane dès le mois
d'août 1940 un certain nombre de marques
un furent équipés d'un radar et ce via
bien que ce radar augmenta les chances
de l'hydravion de localiser un sous
marin il ne s'avérera pas fiable et ce
n'est que lorsque le hsv2 un radar bien
plus performants furent mis au point que
cet appareil furent considérés comme
faisant partie du matériel standard la
seconde variante du sunderland bleus
marquent 2 qui commencent à apparaître
en 1941 fut équipés de ce nouveau radar
afin d'améliorer les performances
le mark ii étaient propulsés par des
moteurs pégase 18 à deux vitesses au
lieu des bécasses 22 qui équipait le
mark 1 les performances des hydravions
s'améliorèrent encore grâce au lancement
du mark iii sunderland
muni d'un n'est plus courts afin d'être
plus facilement manoeuvrable le premier
marc trois produits s'envola pour la
première fois en décembre 1941
afin de répondre aux besoins toujours
croissants d'améliorer l'armement on
augmenta la puissance de tir de certains
nouveaux hydravion le mark iii devint la
principale variante du sunderland
pendant la guerre plus de la moitié des
750 hydravion construits étaient des
marques 3 outre une autre variante le
mark iv propulsé par quatre moteurs
bristol et recule de 1700 chevaux le
second sunderland le plus utilisé fut le
marque 5
équipé du dernier modèle de radar asv
cet appareil devint un formidable
adversaire ses moteurs pratt & whitney
de 1200 chevaux étaient plus fiables que
les moteurs pégase est donné à l'avion
une plus grande autonomie et une plus
grande vitesse de pointe grâce à ses
hélices mise en drapeau il ya ces
moteurs américains le marque 5 pouvait
poursuivre ses vols si les deux moteurs
situés d'un même côté de l'appareil ne
fonctionnait plus avant lui aucun avion
n'était capable de faire ça sans perdre
de l'altitude
entre le premier marc 1 qui fut produit
en 1944 et le dernier sunderland être
construits par l'entreprise en juin 40
650 appareils au total avaient été
produits
ils continueront à faire partie des
hydravions de la f1 jusqu'à leur mise à
la retraite définitive en 1959 je
considérais cet hydravion comme une
véritable merveille
ils n'étaient agréable de partir en
opération à son boy chacun de ses avions
avait onze membres d'équipage entre
autres un capitaine un pilote parfois un
second pilote un navigateur
mon ingénieur un opérateur et trois
membres s'occuper des mitrailleuses
chacun de ces hommes pouvaient être
remplacé au cours d'un vol d'essai ce
qu'était vraiment utile n'est qu'un je
peux vous dire que vous étiez épuisés et
que vos yeux étaient vraiment très
fatigué après quelques heures de vol
depuis ce vous pouviez prendre de repas
un premier repas composé de dollars est
nu steak et des légumes pour le second
c'était très bon mon second pilote était
un japonais il n'avait jamais mangé de
steaks
il trouva le repas très bon c'était un
excellent pilote
malheureusement il est décédé il ya un
mot navigateur faisait vraiment
parfaitement son travail il est mort
également dans un accident d'avion en
espagne
son avion s'est écrasé dans la montagne
à cette époque notre journée étaient
organisées de la façon suivante
nous devions nous prenions notre petit
déjeuner et ensuite nous avions le
briefing
après le briefing nous prenions un canoë
nous montions à bord de l'hydravion par
la porte avant
nous devrions souvent avant l'aube et
nous ne revenions pas avant que la nuit
ne soient tombées ce n'était pas
toujours facile vous deviez en fait
d'abord descendre de quelques 200 pieds
par minute et faire atterrir l'hydravion
dès que vous voyez la première lumière
mais à ce moment là c'était ça devenait
plus simple pour décoller c'était pas
trop compliqué mais il suffisait de
prendre bon élan il vous est impossible
de décoller immédiatement il fallait
prendre un élan il fallait que les
moteurs et atteint la vitesse maximale
de jour comme de nuit de la procédure
d'atterrissage restée la même dans les
deux cas il vous était impossible de
voir quelle distance vous séparait de la
surface de l'eau vous deviez descendre
de quelques 200 pieds par minute essayé
d'atterrir du mieux que vous et le
second pilote
vous indiquez alors quand vous avez
atteint la surface de l'eau je pense que
pendant la guerre la plupart des pilotes
de sunderland était conscient qu'ils
avaient beaucoup de chance laissée nolan
faisait de longs trajets mais l'équipage
pouvait prendre ses repas à bord par
exemple le pilote pouvait se reposer
pendant qu'un autre prenait la relève
n'est en outre ses avions étaient très
fiables
je pense que nous étions très fiers
d'appartenir à l'équipage de sunderland
de plus tout le monde s'entendait très
bien
il n'existait aucune tension entre les
membres de l'équipage et de commandant
il régnait une très bonne ambiance
le sunderland était un avion très fiable
et facile à manoeuvrer
tant que vous disposiez d'une profondeur
suffisante d'eau comme c'est le cas pour
tous les hydravions un peu mou donc nous
avions de l'eau insuffisant s'il
suffisait d'atterrir entre les deux
extrémités du bassin vous intéressiez
alors aussi facilement que sur la terre
ferme et nous avions également à
pembroke dock qu'un bassin dans lequel
les hydravions été réparé et cela
toujours posé problème
comment faut-il réparer un hydravion
alors qu'il se trouve dans l'eau c'était
un problème pour tous les hydravions du
monde
quand j'étais en afrique
nous avions un ingénieur italien un
homme génial qui trouvait une solution à
cette époque était construit un bord
dans la région et y bâtir un dock pour
réparer les hydravions d'incidence est
parti du port
les vagues étaient brisées et l'on
pouvait amener le matériel et travailler
un hydravion sans aucune difficulté
mais dans l'océan atlantique des années
40 ce furent les thunder line qui
luttèrent le plus contre les sous marins
jusqu'à ce qu'un appareil américain le
consolidated catalina 20 leur prêter
main forte
alors que les escadres idée sunderland
continuer à assurer leurs patrouilles
anti sous marins et à escorter des
convois il acquiert également une
excellente réputation pour avoir
effectué des opérations de sauvetage
dangereuse de nombreux hommes doivent la
vie à six missions de secours menées en
plein océan et donnons des côtes au
cours des invasions allemande en norvège
en grèce en crête les hydravions
arrachèrent un grand nombre de soldats
alliés aux griffes des troupes de lax au
cours de l'évacuation de la grèce en
avril 41 1 sunderland de la 228e escadre
in évacuées a pas moins de 80 soldats et
membres du personnel de la force
aérienne en un seul vol si l'on y ajoute
l'équipage à sunderland
l'hydravion tenta de décoller du port de
kalamata avec 90 personnes à bord
quelques jours plus tard les troupes de
parachutistes allemands attaquèrent la
crète et à la fin du mois de mai les
sunderland entrèrent à nouveau en action
cette fois ils devaient assurer des
missions d'évacuation entre adele a
siégé et l'egypte une région sûre en
comparaison de la crète à tarente en
1940 les efforts qu'ils fournir pour
assurer des missions de reconnaissance
vital de la flotte italienne permis à
l'armée de l'air de mener une attaque
victorieuse
tout au long de la guerre les sunderland
et tout particulièrement ceux de la 230e
ex-cadre y accomplir des missions dans
presque toutes les régions entre autres
en europe au moyen-orient et en extrême
orient
cette escadrille changer sans cesse de
base ce qui prouve bien que ces
appareils menèrent démission dans le
monde entier au cours de la seconde
guerre mondiale
parmi ces bases on peut citer mbandjock
celle tard le scellant aboukir la
birmanie au cours de la guerre qui
l'opposait au japon la 230e escadrille
dû évacuer des troupes de birmanie et
peu de temps après lens à l'une des
premières attaques fructueuse contre les
médias japonais
après le jour j d'escadre y participant
aux missions de récupération des troupes
a dit prisonnière des camps japonais
lorsque la guerre prix réellement fin en
europe en mai 45 live décida de
maintenir par simple précaution des
patrouilles anti sous marins pendant un
mois encore la dernière patrouille anti
sous marins fut mené par un sunderland
de l'a2 santé 1e escadrille au cours de
la première semaine du mois de juin 1945
bien que les chiffres us plus tard avait
été corrigé les équipages et sunderland
affirmèrent à la fin de la guerre avoir
coulé 35 sous marin il y en avoir
endommagé g20 autres mais les coûts fut
élevé le nombre de sunderland perdu
pendant la guerre c'était bien au delà
des 200 appareils
au cours des années d'après guerre les
sunderland continue à être très actif au
sein de l'aef
alors qu'un pont aérien était assurée
pour ravitailler la ville de berlin au
cours de la seconde moitié de l'année 48
il transportait plusieurs milliers de
tonnes de denrées vitales au cours de
toute la guerre de corée lee sunderland
du far east flying boat wing basés au
japon firent plus de 1500 sorties et
enregistrèrent près de 14 de 1000 heures
de vol entre 51 54 les hydravions de
l'a2 santé unis à mes 200 30e escadre y
transporter les hommes et le matériel de
l'expédition britannique au nord du
groenland
en 1957 un avion britannique de grande
taille en atterrissant sur la terre
ferme et est en fin de compte devenu
moins coûteux et plus rapide et plus
efficace que le sunderland v que la
carrière et sunderland toucher à sa fin
toutes les escadres y stationner sur des
bases nationales furent dispersées et la
majorité de leurs avions connurent une
feinte indigne puisqu'ils furent vendus
pour devenir de la vulgaire ferraille à
celle tard les hydravions de la 205e
mais 209e escadrille basée en extrême
orient furent les seuls à continuer à
servir dans l'armée
vu de l'extérieur on dépit de son fort
tonnage cet hydravion donner une
étonnante impression de solidité et
d'élégance sont au fuselage et son large
mais souligne encore cette apparence de
distinction
sa solidité sa vaste capacité de
transport et son puissant armement de
défense lui permettait de remplir
efficacement un grand nombre de rôles
adoré par ses équipages et hautement
respecté par ses ennemis
le sunderland vain une véritable légende
de tous les hydravions qui ont servi
dans la rff le sunderland fut le dernier
est sans aucun doute le meilleur
je ne sais pas ce que je pourrais encore
ajouté le sunderland était un très bon
appareil tout le monde l'aimait en tous
les cas je ne connais personne qui n'ait
pas apprécié cet avion mais il fut
rattrapé par le temps
bientôt apparaîtrait les grands jets et
le sunderland aurait alors perdu toute
sa raison d'être
les grands jets avaient besoin de vastes
piste d'atterrissage et on en construit
évidemment pour eux ensuite s'y ajoute
encore la haute technologie
le radar d'autres instruments de ce
genre que le sud de l'aisne ne possède
évidemment pas mais je pense qu'en son
temps le sunderland fait un excellent
travail et qu'il fit très très bien son
travail
tout le monde aimait le sunderland
quand vous étiez à bord de cet énorme
appareil vous aviez l'impression d'être
un géant il était très différent du mien
c'était un énorme appareil vous aviez
l'impression de pouvoir faire tout ce
que vous vouliez avec un tel appareil
lorsque vous étiez attaqués cet avion
vous permettait de virer de bord
facilement c'était un superbe hydravion
m
non
pas
le mauvais temps
là